Millennials,
when you grow up in a world of
abundance,
you're basic needs are met,
so like that's just an expectation.
Of course I'm going to get a salary and
of course I'm going to get benefits.
What I want is a job that has meaning to
me that connects to my life purpose and
you can only have that if you have a
really strong culture that says,
here's who we are as an organization.
Here's what,
here's what matters,
here's why it matters to us to be this
way.
Organizations that are clear on that are
going to be more appealing to
millennials than the organizations that
simply say,
we do xY,
,
z work and we have this opening position
and you should,
you should work for us.
And and that's it.
The organizations we saw,
they're doing this or designing their
organizations around the needs of the
employees,
not the needs of management and they're
making it work,
experience customizable and they're
building in continuous innovation and
improvement into management,
which is new,
right?
We used to sort of come up with our best
practice and as soon as we have that,
we did that for the next 20 years.
Uh,
that doesn't work anymore.
We have to be more fluid.
The traditional organization a relies
heavily on hierarchy and heavily on a
paying your dues,
right?
So in order to advance in the company,
the standard rule is you have to come
there,
you have to work,
you have to do,
you have to do work you don't like for a
certain period of time so that you can
graduate to a different level where you
get to do work that's a little bit
better and then work some more and then
eventually start managing people and
eventually started having authority to
make decisions or do things on your own.
That organization just doesn't make
sense to millennials.
I mean,
we interviewed millennials for this book
and the general theme from our response
from the millennials was,
why are you guys running it like this?
Like they're literally scratching their
heads saying,
why would you,
why would you run an organization like
this?
Why would you not empower people who are
closest to the customer,
for instance,
to make a decision?
Why would you,
why would you not share information like
that's a huge women organizations and
millennials don't get to some extent,
the earlier generations are going to
have to learn to give up control.
Uh,
that's a,
that's a big theme I'm seeing in
organizations that,
that,
you know,
most of our management systems are based
on control being a good thing.
And I'm finding organizations that give
up on that actually you get to achieve
more.
And so I think the smart organizations
are going to get clear looking at their
millennial workforce,
much of much of whom are going to be
entry level to say,
I know you're entry level,
but in this area I'm going to let you
run with it.
Like within these walls,
you can do whatever you want,
you can experiment,
you can be in charge.
Uh,
and so you've just got to be clear about
where those walls are so that they don't
have huge impacts on the rest of the
enterprise.
Uh,
but find places early on to do that.
So they have the experience of making
their own decisions.
I also think in general,
organizations will be pleasantly
surprised when they start letting their
employees experiment because I think
they'll start seeing results that they
wouldn't have predicted that they
wouldn't get.